et
une
m
où
conquest afat chad à manier sur nos
soldats tous nos maux mais encaissait au
lieu qu'ils avaient comme emma cas
patcher soldes essonniens
mettre la main une autre sono est bon à
l'italien oui c'est une étrange chansons
que mes taxes vraiment du vcp en
australie c'est une chanson que j'ai du
plaisir à chanter en italien parce que
la traduction n'est encore plus + eric
le text penser mais c'est celle ci aussi
jani avec l'italien qui date de mes
ancêtres
alors georges tu es tu y mets devenir
l'egypte oui comme beaucoup c'est votre
jour avec drucker on a recensé tous les
grecs bien mais jusqu en a quelques-uns
savez alexandrie alexandrie qu'elle fait
des études du mal de ce qui est exigé
par le groupe comme une langue je ne
voulais pas plus ou moins bien celle que
je parle bien sûr le grec parce que par
les hasards de la guerre ou la première
scolarité j'avais fait en france et puis
j'ai pris goût puce
j'ai fait toutes mes études en français
dès que j'ai passé mon bac que ceux
venus en france et je ne peux de grecs
je gardais si loin dans ma mémoire enfin
quand je retourne en grèce je retrouve
un peu lent mais ses rangs tu parles
italien espagnol anglais et bourges
arabe portugais portugais tu as appris
de la musique jeudi par petits bouts oui
tu as commencé deux voies de piano puis
à 17 ans 6 mois de solfège à 18 et la
guitare 20 ans lui en suivre et j'aime
explique alors à 17 ans tu arrives à
paris gare de lyon
tu venais de déterminer parc à marseille
lui arrive et l'egypte et puis
tu vas tu vas chercher du travail dû
commencer à écrire des chansons déjà
non je fais je cherchais pas du travail
mais on propose assez vite
il savait c'est de vendre des recueils
de poèmes en porte à porte ou dans les
terrasses de café et c'était un travail
plaisant parce que le marché du porte à
porte n'était pas saturé alors nous
ouvrait la porte facilement il y avait
une des aventures extraordinaires qui se
passait dehors tu avais pas peur a au
contraire c'était très excitant
tous les groupes de jeunes gens qui
faisaient ça c'était c'était des jeunes
filles avec qui ont continué la soirée
après le travail
c'était c'était vraiment pas un travail
pénible en plus été rentable
c'était par rapport à nos besoins à 7 et
rentable je veux dire on vivait la
bohème c'est vrai qu'on faisait pas le
repas gastronomique mais on aurait pas
de fin et on s'amusait beaucoup et puis
tu commences écrire des chansons et tu
fais les gens s'emparent montant
salvador échos j'écris des chansons et
puis c'est plus embêtant
il nous fallait démontrer qu'il est
timide ou timides orgueilleux je ne peux
pas savoir mais deux murs ah bon mais
c'est que c'était très pénible alors
quelquefois la chance a joué en ma
faveur par exemple un jour je vais à la
bc pour voir salvador que j'adorais que
j'adore toujours voulu monter une
chanson que j'avais écrite en pensant
lui
enfin pendant qu'il pourrait la chanter
et j'entre dans sa loge et je vois une
dame qui est l'un kindy vous voulez voir
henry je dis madame vous avez l'accent
et égyptien se l'était succès dit oui
sud d'alexandrie
or la grande diffusion henri salvador en
tri persuadé je suis un ami de
jacqueline parce que j'active déjà
regretté égyptienne et c'est à la
famille invite au spectacle vont même
digne du nom de la chanson l'a fait une
registre
et puis made in au fond vous connaissez
depuis longtemps jacqueline
ici on s'est connus le jour où nous
avions ensemble mais la chose ça oui
parce que plusieurs fois je suis allé
jusqu'à une porte d'une vedette pour
montrer ma chanson je n'ai pas et nous
j'ai pas voulu qu'on se le dise et par
vous orgueilleux par timidité je n'ai
pas été plus loin que le palier sur des
cendres hier avec annick comment ça
s'est passé là encore bas aussi c'était
le hasard bien heureux et agréable
j'avais commis un homme qui ment
beaucoup à ma vie à la vie de vos
cookies et henri crolla avait quitté le
tatami montant unitaire est de mon temps
formidable musicien unitariste
extraordinaire enfin je galérais pas
d'éloges pas c'est vraiment une
personnalité importante dans ma vie dans
ma musique et on avait un petit problème
quand on veut qu'ils auraient pu nous en
faisait histoire de deux heures qui se
ressemblent et le ses lumières on devait
en discuter
quand on était en présence on a oublié
de s'engueuler ou de se chercher des
histoires on a plutôt envisager de faire
des chansons bien faire n'importe quoi
ensemble et non le n'importe quoi faire
ensemble et avaient rendez vous avec
lesdites eelv et le jour même mais dit
tu es avec moi on se quitte pas jeudi
noir n'ont essayé je n'ai pas quitté
puis répétés dit je reste pas mon nom
mais je suis entré chez dit comme ça
pour être avec roland aimerait emmener
où que ce soit j'aurais suivi
il se trouve que les choses je disais le
sommet n'était pas encore composé rien
pour est dit
j'avais une chanson que j'avais composé
en espérant rencontrer edith piaf un
jour et j'ai voulu la montrer dit
et puis j'étais il se veut dépasser par
les évènements fin 17 et plus et que tu
ne pensais oui je t'ai pas prêt enfin la
situation
on joue au piano qui n'est pas mon
instrument de prédilection
j'essaie de lui jouer féminité
venez me voir chanter de bord vous
m'écrivez des chansons joie parce que
c'est ce que vous connaissez nous
montrer et puis quelques mois plus tard
lundi cette chanson tu m'avais montrer
parce qu'on était au tueur n'est fait
beaucoup de choses ensemble
qu'est-ce que c'était au fond et je lui
ai joué alors là dans le calme et avec
un avait de la sollicitude on
l'écouterait plus d'intérêt plus
d'attention et elle a aimé elle a fait
un très beau disque c'est une chanson
qui s'appelle le gîte à la fille qui ne
pétain c'est comment faire
le gîte en inde et à la fille qu'importe
le prix de l'amour il faut pas le
chanter parce que elle afin disent
tellement merveilleux et la faune
plusieurs disques mes chansons mais
c'est l'une à il est marqué d'une grâce
exceptionnelle
je crois même que dans l'absolu n'est
jamais aussi bien chanté
elle était dans une forme vocale tout à
fait tout à fait comparable et puis bon
il est qu une chanson qui ont eu plus de
succès donc l'ultime elle est un peu
oublié mais ça reste pour moi la chanson
que j'aime est fait pour édith avant de
reconnaître qu'il a chanté
magnifiquement puis après déjà fait
mille arbres proell oui mais alors je
lui ai fait sur mesure et ça j'aime ça
d'ailleurs j'aime bien écrire pour
quelqu'un en sachant que c'est quelqu'un
à chanter donc on s'identifie où on
cherche les mots qui serait à la fois ce
qu'on a envie d'écrire mais ceux de ma
personne peut chanter ou vient de
transfert des sensibilités c'est très
excitant c'est un dédoublement
le récit prend déjà écrit pour les gens
si différents go comme montant salvador
comme ricco comme barbara harel chagny
colette renard jamais je n'y renonce
qu'un projet mais tu oublies quelqu'un
qui était important parce que c'était
une de mes idoles de l'adolescence était
une rossi ah oui bien sûr
vous j'écris jeunes gens voulaient
absolument ne pas finir ma carrière de
compositeur sans écrire pour tous nos et
grâce à un film qui s'appelait jusqu'au
bout du monde où j'ai fais la musique
devrait les acteurs montent il faut bien
en faire une chanson parce que le film
se passe est encore jeune et qu'il ouvre
aussi une plaisir tous les jours qu'a
duré la pétition on y voit passer des
heures indique lui et c'était je crois
que c'est une des dernières sont sont
disons des derniers succès de steam
cette chanson et ça c'est une grande
récompense relative apathie sur les
routes faire des tournées à partir de
nom quelques jours je fais très grande
tournée en espagne et 1 se disait j'ai
trouvé plusieurs patrie sur ma route et
l'espagne est un pays que je n'ai connu
qu'après le franquisme parce que je
vivais une censure d'ailleurs c'est
contre certaines chansons sont pas
pourquoi elles sont pas si si véhémente
même si une disent les choses que je
pense on le réalise bien les jouer aussi
oui chantant en espagnol mais je n'en
veux ce cru
je suis français depuis peu mais je suis
un chanteur français plus longtemps
j'incite un français de plus il s'était
confirmée mais je chante partout sauf au
japon en allemagne en espagne du sud du
nord en français parce que je pense que
la chanson est intraduisible